نعم لا شك ان الانباء تتضارب حول ماهيه
معبر او هل المعبر ما زال مفتوحا ام اغلق
لكن عمليا انا راح اصدر داخل المعبر هنالك
يعني ايصال العديد من جسامين الذين قد
سقطوا نتيجه لهذه الكارثه الانسانيه
المركبه التي حصلت في الداخل التركي وكذلك
ايضا في الداخل السوري عمليا دخلت تسعه
دخلت تسعه صهاريج محمله بالوقود وتحديدا
بماده الديزل الى الداخل السوري هذا مؤكد
وانا رصدته وقمت بتصويره بشكل مباشر منذ
الساعه قريبه الرابعه عصرا البارحه بمعنى
اخر ان الجهات التركيه تقوم بايصال هذه
المساعدات لكن عمليا ربما المساعدات
الامميه لم تصل بعد وانما هنالك معلومات
انا قد جمعت المساعدات وانا في طريقها الى
تركيا لكن هل وصلت الى تركيا هل من
معلومات دقيقه لدى الامم المتحده تؤكد
انها وصلت الى مطارات علما بان المعبر
المعبر الان يعني هو مفتوح صحيح
ولا 24 ساعه اكد لي احد العاملين في مجال
نقله جثامين الضحايا اكد لي بان المعبر
سيبقى يعمل على مدار 24 ساعه وذلك للسبب
الرئيسي وهو ان هنالك العديد من الجسامين
الذين يتم انتشارهم من تحت الانقاض من
مدينتي نارلجا وكذلك ايضا كرخان المدينتين
المدمرتين بشكل شبه كامل ايضا يتم نقل
جفاهيم الضحايا باتجاه مدينه الريحانيه
هنالك مستشفى من اجل تسجيل وتوثيق اسماء
الذين قد سقطوا نتيجه لهذا الزلزال كذلك
ايضا من اجل ادخالها من الجانب السوري
بشكل يعني
منظم كذلك ايضا على الطرف الاخر انا شاهدت
ايضا وانا موجود داخل المعبر قرابه الساعه
الخامسه عصرا او قبل المغرب بقليل دخلت
شاحنه تقل يعني على متنها خبز شاحنه
وكامله ايضا لاحظت خروج مجموع الثلاث
شاحنات من الداخل السوري فارغه من اجل
ربما في الغالب سيكون بمواد اما غذائيه
واما حاجيات اولويات بالنسبه للمتواجدين
على الطرف الاخر من الحدود